[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis d'avoir trouvé pour
un nouveau numéro des matins du sénat
les missions qui vous fait revivre les
débats de la haute assemblée les
sénateurs ont adopté hier le troisième
budget d'urgence pour faire face à la
crise du coronavirus 45 milliards
d'euros afin de sauver l'économie de
venir en aide aux plus démunis
les sénateurs ont voté leur propre
dispositif de prime à l'embauché des
jeunes
ils ont validé leur repas à 1 euro pour
les étudiants boursiers une mesure
annoncée par le président de la
république
emmanuel macron et enfin les sénateurs
ont facilité le déblocage de l'epargne
salariale afin de relancer la
consommation
je vous laisse écouter les débats il
s'agit évidemment d'un amendement sur
l'ile-de-france mobilité pertes estimées
au total 2 milliards 600 millions pertes
estimées pour le seul versement mobilité
1 milliard pourquoi c'est assez simple
le confinement a fait que nous avons mis
ont été mis en chômage
un certain nombre de salariés est par
définition les entreprises n'ont pas
versé les sommes habituel dans un
premier temps le gouvernement dans son
texte imaginé ne rien indemnisés pour
idf m
rien pas un kopeck je sais pas pourquoi
est ce que c'est parce qu'il y avait le
temps pauvre île de france
c'est c'est non toujours est il est vrai
rien puis dans un deuxième temps
amendement du rapporteur à l'assemblée
nationale laurent de saint-martin et on
nous fait la grâce d'une indemnité pour
solde de tout compte
à un peu plus de 400 millions et je vous
dis le la simple le simple l'assam non
perception du versement mobilité c'est
un milliard c'est deux milliards et demi
j'y reviendrai j'ai un autre amendement
un peu plus loin avec l'amendement 17
mai c'est pas raisonnable
et quand vous me dites moi elle pas
d'idées mais quand vous allez nous dire
ah ben nous on fait une moyenne
enfin en l'occurrence vous fait même pas
de moyenne vous vouliez rien nous donner
donc dont c'était la moyenne à 0 mais
même si vous faites une moyenne
sauf que les taux du versement mobilité
en ile de france ont augmenté en 2018
2010 donc faire une moyenne avec 2017 ou
les taux est évidemment bien inférieur
c'est absurde le lire or l'île de france
chacun le sait c'est 5 millions
d'usagers des transports
c'est la moitié du versement mobilité de
toute la france c'est 60% des
utilisateurs du métro du rer ou des
trains de banlieue et nous sommes dans
l'incapacité de poursuivre l'ensemble
des fonctions si nous n'avons pas une
indemnisation par l'état alors la
présidente de région avait dit on arrête
et puis l'état dit manière très très
autoritaire parce qu'après tout la ratp
sncf sont deux entreprises publiques
nationales qui ne dépendent pas de la
région donc c'est à vous de le faire
vous dit non non ça continuera mais ça
continuera avec quel argent
donc monsieur le ministre un geste au
moins compenser le versement mobilité
donc ensuite il ya un amendement de
monsieur marcel défendu président très
bien madame derrière donc ensuite il y a
le 769 rectifié monsieur huchon défendu
ensuite 909 de monsieur savoldelli
défendu ensuite monsieur le rapporteur
général
le premier de deux amendements
identiques
j'avoue que j'ai pas toujours eu
beaucoup de temps pour examiner les
amendements mais c'est une question que
j'ai essayé de regarder quand tu dis des
enjeux et des montants qui ont été
rappelés un instant par roger karoutchi
tu nommes de franciliens qui fréquentent
les transports que j'ai regardé de
manière un peu approfondis compris le 14
juillet donc très concrètement pour ceux
qui ont besoin d'un petit rappel
initialement il était rien prévu ensuite
l'assemblée nationale a introduit un
acompte qui est n'est pas évidemment de
moins de 500 millions d'euros qui n'est
pas à la hauteur des pertes de recettes
les pertes elles sont doubles c'est
d'une part le versement mobilité qui
s'est évidemment un kbc et ce sont les
recettes commerciales
qui se sont effondrés puisque par
définition il n'y avait pas de voyageurs
un touriste pas de salariés qui venaient
et les gens n'ont pas acheté les passes
magiques navigo donc il ya un double
fond demandé de recettes commerciales ou
inversement mobilité donc on essaie de
regarder de la manière la plus précise
comment compenser taux d'endettement
raisonnable donc sa raison des trois
amendements que je vous présente le 391
majeur l'acompte versé à ile-de-france
mobilité pour tenir compte de la perte
réelle au titre des versements mobilité
donc initialement je vous le disais à
l'instant il était prévu 425 millions
d'euros et j'ai échangé avec les
services de france mobilité j'ai eu la
base des chiffres réels et le ont donc à
la place de 425 millions ça serait 920
millions d'acompte qui corresponde à la
réalité des chiffres et d'estimations
très concrètement s'est basé sur une
baisse de 20% du du versement mobilité
l'important c'est sans doute raisonnable
20% par rapport aux produits de
référence donc donc premier amendement
le 391 major l'acompte à la place de 425
millions d'euros il prévoit 920 millions
d'euros
dans la pratique les chiffres vous pas
vous paraîtra énorme et dans la pratique
cette façon s'il y avait prévu en 2020
une compensation aurait elle donc autant
que l'acompte soit le plus proche
possible du réel et de la réalité il est
prévu qu on fera les comptes en 2021 et
qu on ajustera le solde
le deuxième amendement je vous présente
en même temps si vous le permettez pas
la cohérence du débat il ya également
des est un amendement comme ça j'aime
être à dire venir 392 il fixe une date
butoir pour le versement de cet acompte
que l'on ne traîne pas cette question et
de versement doit intervenir au plus
tard le 1er mars prochain et le
troisième amendement
modifie le produit versement de
référence du percement mobilité donc
vous avez en tête la règle de la moyenne
dont on a parlé à l'instant mais l'île
de france et une session très
particulière puisque il ya eu des
rattrapage tarifaire due notamment à la
mise en place du pass navigo unique
je ne sais pas c'est au sommet de débats
loi de finances ya quelques années ça
nous a occupés quelques soirées donc je
vais nous étions là tous et nous avons
eu évidemment le financement de ce pass
navigo avec notamment un rattrapage une
sorte de rattrapage tarifaire annoncée à
l'avant ce qui a fait que le versement
mobilité et plus dynamique qu'en
province par exemple ils augmentaient je
rappelle de 3,2 pour cent par an entre
2017 et 2019 donc concrètement
l'amendement vise à prendre en compte
mais ce rattrapage
bien sûr on est à la fois dans la
référence à la moyenne 2010 et 2017 2019
si on ne faisait pas ça ferait perdre
pour être 250 millions d'euros de francs
d'euros pardon avec de france mobilité
voilà donc les objets des trois
amendements augmenter la conte
deuxièmement vers prévoir le versement
de l'acompte avant mars 2021
et troisièmement tenir un compte des
augmentations tarifaires des
augmentations pardon tu passes le dieu
pour le financement du pass mobilité je
pense qu'on arrivera à quelque chose qui
sera plus juste et en tout état de cause
monsieur me dit ça fait rien par l'état
puisque le sol dans la loi doit être
ottomane et versé en 2021 donc je
rejoins pour terminer ce que disait un
instant au rejet karoutchi ou d'autres
sans doute on n'a pas le choix parce que
c'est un syndicat qui n'a pas droit
déficit est la seule variable
d'ajustement serait serait contraint
d'arrêter les investissements ce qui
serait impensable je pense que si on
prend le rer b où les lignes 13 les fait
bander et tous les jours je peux pas
considérer pas considéré que les
conditions de transport soient bonnes en
ile de france il ya les jeux olympiques
il ya des conditions de transport des
femmes voilà et donc voit pas que
l'investissement un moment parlent tous
de la relance il ne faudra pas que
l'investissement soit la variable
d'ajustement
cinq catastrophes de 12 à 8 un soutien
les trois amendements comme ça je vous
aurais été fourni merci monsieur
président de rien mais
on se remet dans l'ordre parce que vous
avez défendu des amendements identiques
à d'autres collègues qui doit pouvoir
défendre leurs amendements
et donc il y a monsieur pieds-noirs
peut-être pour le 676 actif vous le
permettez monsieur président pour dire
que les 676 677 sont défendus sont
identiques à ceux de la commission
déposée par monsieur vandelli donc très
bien donc tout est défendue il reste que
l'avis du gouvernement en fait sur cette
série bien merci monsieur le président
la situation d'ile-de-france mobilité et
une situation évidemment particulière
puisque ce monsieur karoutchi qui le
disaient concentration des voyageurs
concentration de la perception du
vêtement mobilité et la densité du
réseau ainsi du programme
d'investissements que l'on connaît c'est
ce qui a amené dans un premier temps et
encore aujourd'hui d'ailleurs le
gouvernement a proposé un traitement
spécifique d'ile-de-france mobilité de
ne pas le traiter comme les autres
essayez en charge de cette fonction
d'autorité organisatrice des mobilités
s'est fié à présider au fait que dans
une première version le projet loi de
finances ne comportait pas de
dispositions que ce projet a été
améliorée
à l'initiative du rapporteur général de
la commission des finances de
l'assemblée laurent saint martin à
hauteur de 425 millions d'euros y
compris pour permettre à ile-de-france
mobilité et d'avoir une aide en
trésorerie à l'échelle de cet exercice
2020 ce qui nous paraît à ce stade
devoir permettre à une france mobilité
de tenir l'année si vous me permettez
une expression un peu triviale
nous savons qu'il ya un travail à faire
sur ile-de-france mobilité et j'ai en
tête les propos du rapporteur hier
lorsqu'il évoquait la possibilité
d'examiner des pistes avance
remboursable de regarder comment nous
pouvions trouver une solution qui
permette à ile-de-france mobilité de
fonctionner et qui soit respectueuse des
intérêts de chacun j'ai même en tête
monsieur le prime sur la porte en
général vos propos disant que la vérité
était certainement quelque part entre la
position initiale du gouvernement et la
demande que je qualifierais un peu
maximaliste de d'ile-de-france mobilité
je pense à la demande à hauteur de 2
milliards
600 millions d'euros qui fait l'objet
d'ailleurs d'un amendement de monsieur
symbole de vie à ce stade et je dis bien
à ce stade parce que je ne veux pas que
cet avis apparaissent comme une fin de
non recevoir ou contre ou pire encore le
refus d'une discussion et d'un travail
l'avis du gouvernement est défavorable à
ces amendements
j'ai eu un contact je précise très
succinct par sms pour vous ne rien vous
cacher avec la présidente
d'ile-de-france mobilité nous sommes
convenus de nous voir aussi rapidement
que possible pour là aussi explorer les
pistes de travail et la manière dont on
peut trouver un accord c'est la raison
pour laquelle à ce stade je le répète le
gouvernement était favorable
ça n'est pas une fin de non-recevoir
nine portes claquées loin s'en faut
c'est le besoin la nécessité absolue de
travailler de manière très approfondie
sur un sujet qui vous en conviendrez
l'image images originales monsieur le
rapporteur par vos amendements vous avez
monsieur le rapporteur par vos
amendements vous avez forcément donner
un avis sur les identique mais pas sur
les autres donc pouvez vous me donner
l'avis de la commission sur les
amendements de messieurs karoutchi et
marseille et de monsieur savoldelli et
damier
alors évidemment les amendements
identiques lavier évident donc pour les
autres moi j'ai pas juste échangé par
sms avec la présidente j'ai lu
longuement j'ai également les services
et donc on essayer d'affiner des
chiffres et donc je pense qu'on est sans
doute quelque chose qui est beaucoup
plus proche de la réalité je pense que
ça tient compte surtout de jeudi a des
spécificités sur lesquels je reviens pas
donc sont les autres amendements c'est
une demande de retrait ou de ralliement
est bon contenu du verre de risque a dit
le président du nombre d'abonnements qui
restent en discussion comme ils vont
tous dans le même sens je vais demander
si vous êtes encore la priorité sur le
281 points 4 et 11 pouces et 13 de la
commission
ainsi que celui de monsieur mans des
déviations qui est identique ce qui
permettrait de satisfaire je pense dans
leur attention moi tous les auteurs des
amendements est ce que par étape était
de gagner du temps donc demande dont
donc pour être précis je suis saisi
d'une demande priorités de la commission
afin que les amendements identiques 391
et 676 rectifié l'amendement numéro 3
192 et les amendements identiques 393 et
6 ans sont 17 rectifié soit mis aux voix
avant l'ensemble des amendements de la
discussion commune
selon l'article 44 alinéa 6 de notre
règlement la priorité de droit quand
elle est demandée par la commission
saisie au fond sauf opposition du
gouvernement
d'ailleurs s'ils s'opposent ça ne bloque
pas tout c'est le sénat lui-même qui
décidera par un vote la priorité ou pas
monsieur le ministre
être vous opposer merci monsieur le
président il n'y a aucune raison pour le
gouvernement de s'opposer une demande de
priorités de la commission se ferait au
mieux inélégant je voulais simplement et
c'est la raison de ma demande de prise
de parole précisé que sur l'amendement
392 de monsieur le rapporteur qui si
j'ai bonne mémoire et celui qui qui
touche à la date de versement du solde
définitif
je voulais appeler l'attention du sénat
sur le fait qu'au delà des positions que
j'ai exprimés sur le contenu des
amendements qui le précède
nous n'avons pas la certitude que les
comptes soient définitivement arrêtée au
31 mars si nous avons plutôt même la
certitude inverse
je préférerais que ce soit dit pour que
le sénat ne soient pas surpris en cas de
difficultés en la matière
l'allemande s'est pas opposé à la
demande en priorité donc la priorité est
ordonnée et
mais il y a des demandes d'explications
de vote donc monsieur karoutchi vous
avez la parole chers collègues celui de
monsieur président part dans deux subi
ce temps je pourrai jouer sur les mots
parce qu en fait l'amendement de la
commission ne ferrand rien de tomber le
mien puisque l'amendement de la
commission c'est une compensation
forfaitaire et moi je demande à ce que
on respecte le fait de reprendre la
totalité du versement mobilité perdu en
2020 je parle pas pour le moment de
compensation forfaitaire
d'autant que j'ai un autre amendement
qui vient un peu plus loin et qui va en
reparler sur un autre sujet je serais
tenté de dire au rapporteur général
confiance absolue dans la mesure où je
sais parfaitement qui a eu des
discussions négociations avec la
présidence d'ile-de-france mobilité
qu'après tout si on trouve une voie de
passage pourquoi pas en revanche
monsieur le ministre j'ai une inquiétude
non dissimulée
c'est que ici vous nous dites que
naturellement vous allez avoir un
contact avec la présidente
mais à l'assemblée vous avez une
majorité tranquille si je puis dire si à
l'assemblée
enfin tranquille oui elle ne l'aurait
sont pas là mais en tout état de cause
ici vous pouvez nous dire ben on est
ouvert on discute puis à l'assemblée
revenir à la position initiale de
laurent saint martin ce qui dans le fond
nous ramènera la position de départ
ce qui n'est évidemment pas
l'ouverture que nous attendons
franchement je vous le dis moi j'accepte
naturellement de retirer l'amendement 18
au profit des amendements de la
commission
mais attention parce qu'au delà de la
compensation
ça veut dire que pour le moment et en
tous cas dans les mois qui viennent la
région ne pourra pas passer les
commandes de matériel nouveau qu'elle
attendait pour renouveler les rames et
quand on sait le retard qu'on a pris sur
le matériel roulant en ile de france
c'est une catastrophe pour les millions
d'usagers
c'est tout alors après on peut me parler
d'écologie de transition écologique de
nécessité si vous ne faites pas un
effort sur les transports publics
je ne sais pas comment on va faire pour
qu'en ile-de-france la transition
écologique et du centre mais en
attendant je retire l'amendement au
profit de ceux de la commission
bon je répète il serait tombé car cet
amendement très très que que vous
défendiez modifier la linea car ou neuf
dont l'amendement propose une nouvelle
rédaction global donc si si c'est si
beau regarder bien donc de toutes façons
vous l'avait retiré mais il serait tombé
donc ou coquines et les prises de parole
avec madame dumas vous avez la parole
remercie monsieur le président bon moi
j'ai bien entendu les propos de son
rapporteur général aussi ceux du
ministre avec plus de réserve et je
voudrais dire que je me rallie
complètement à ce que roger karoutchi
vient de dire revenir à l'amendement de
l'assemblée nationale ne s'est
absolument pas raisonnable et ne peut
pas être envisageable alors il faut
absolument qu'on prenne en compte cette
situation de la région ile de france
on l'a dit les 5 millions d'usagers
c'est la région capitale c'est son
économie qui est en jeu donc moi je
soutiens vraiment qu'on revienne à un
mécanisme de compensation à hauteur des
pertes fiscales qui sont induites par la
crise
et halak au vide et non pas quelque
chose de forcé terre et donc je
souhaiterais que ce soit entendue dans
cet hémicycle
ensuite monsieur ouzoulias collègues
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues
notre commission de la culture qui qui
gère aussi les sports avait entendu
monsieur castex qui était à l'époque
délégué interministériel pour les jeux
olympiques et qui étiez venu nous
expliquer ici au sénat que les
engagements de la france s'agissant des
transports publics de l'île de france
était un engagement ferme qui avait
conditionné l'octroi des jeux olympiques
à paris en 2024
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il est premier
ministre je n'imagine pas un seul
instant qu'ils puissent revenir sur les
engagements pris par ce gouvernement
par ailleurs vous savez qu'il ya un
autre dossier qui nous occupe c'est le
cdg express auquel nous sommes opposés
alors cela vous n'y touchez pas en
revanche nous les usagers de la ligne b
usagers quotidiens de la ligne b nous
avons compris que les investissements
qui sont déterminants monsieur karoutchi
l'adie pour le matériel roulant mais
c'est aussi vrai pour les
infrastructures
nous avons vécu une semaine
d'interruption du trafic à la suite d'un
problème d'aiguillage à denfert
rochereau
donc c'est quelque chose de fondamental
pour les quotidien'' pour le quotidien
nous avons besoin de ces investissements
si vous ne possédez pas à une
compensation intégrale des pertes
d'ile-de-france mobilité nous n'aurons
pas d'investissement c'est à dire que
nous continuerons à utiliser des des
services dégradés je n'imagine pas un
seul instant comment paris pour
accueillir les jeux olympiques dans ces
conditions
bien monsieur l'arménie vous avez la
parole oui merci monsieur le président
c'est lui ce char collègues étant
consignataires de deux amendements qui
sont communs à celui du rapporteur
général donc amendement de monsieur
mondély 676 rectifier et 677 rectifier
notre collègue qui est également le cas
et elle rapporteur de la loi sur la
mobilité
il ya quelques temps même si je
représente un département plutôt rurale
de 180 mille habitants les ardennes je
crois que on doit s'intéresser aussi aux
contraintes
des parisiens et je crois que c'est pour
ça que je me permets de prendre la
parole puisque je dirais je suis aussi
usagers du métro du rer des transilien
j'ai pu mesurer j'ai pu mesurer j'irai y
compris dans la période de confinement
et après confinement j'irai le
l'engagement le dévouement des
personnels
mon intervention lapointe caractère
financier immédiat mais il faut j'irai
aussi en parler puisse mettre aussi à la
place des parisiens j'irai qui utilisent
les ailes et qui utilisent les
transports en commun matin et soir et
tous les jours donc je crois qu'à ce
niveau là après je dirais pour les les
baisses de recettes et le versement le
versement mobilité en fait partie
puisque j'irai le versement mobilité
c'est malheureusement au moins 2
milliards de de de recettes et alors que
le vin que le versement mobilité pour au
plan national c'est plus de 8 milliards
dont moitié pour ile-de-france mobilité
et les soldes pour la province donc je
pense que là cette perte de 2 milliards
et c'est pour ça que je soutiendrai bien
entendu le ces amendements
notamment julie j'ai cosigné ce que j'ai
cosigné mais en liaison avec le
rapporteur général et qui augmente à
hauteur de 920 millions d'euros pour
l'amendement 391 dont je je le
soutiendrai mais je crois qu'il faut que
ceux de provinces soutiennent aussi les
collègues de région parisienne alors
bien et bien un un sénateur de paris va
prendre la parole monsieur féraud merci
monsieur le président mais qu'ajouter à
ce qu'a dit marc laménie ce qui est très
notable c'est que quel que soit les
dispositifs ou les montants nous sommes
tous très convergent ce qui est
incroyable c'est que au motif que la
situation d'ile-de-france mobilité
serait spécifique plutôt que de prévoir
autre chose
il n'y a rien et on présente depuis déjà
maintenant plusieurs semaines
l'amendement voté à l'initiative de
monsieur saint martin à l'assemblée
nationale comme répondant à la question
or il répond à un sixième de la question
en terme en termes budgétaires
je ne crois pas que la somme de 2,6
milliards soit maximaliste
elle correspond aux chiffres que nous
avons tous et qui est la réalité
donc bien sûr que nous voterons
amendement de compromis qui est un
compromis provisoire est proposée par
par le rapporteur général bien sûr mais
c'est quand même incroyable que nous
devions procéder comme ça et nous
n'avons pas de garantie que cela jusque
à la loi de finances rectificative votée
au riz en a absolument besoin dans tous
les trous de cpl fr on ne parle jamais
de celui des transports en ile-de-france
or il est gigantesque et c'est un enjeu
majeur ça concerne ile de france
ça concerne en réalité toute la nation
ça concerne la vie quotidienne ça
concerne les investissements d'avenir la
préparation des géo et la transit
écologique donc la position du
gouvernement de départ est assez
incroyable
nous lui permettons vraiment peut-être
de sortir d'une ornière mais nous ne
pourront évidemment pas nous en arrêter
là et pour avoir si permettez monsieur
le président vécu beaucoup de débats sur
les questions fiscales budgétaires de
dotation en rapport avec les
collectivités locales
on sentait les élections municipales
comme un peu sous jacente dans les
relations entre le gouvernement et
les parlementaires représentant ces
collectivités ces territoires pardon là
il ne faudrait pas abordé la question
d'ile-de-france mobilité en ayant les
élections régionales en tête je pense
que le gouvernement ferait une grave
erreur et je le dis alors que je ne suis
absolument pas un soutien politique de
la présidente de la région ile de france
ou de sa majorité
je pense que c'est important d'avoir
d'abord l'intérêt général en tête sur
cette question alors que nous savons
qu'il ya des échéances électorales l'an
prochain merci monsieur d'allier
président messieurs ministre coup une
fois n'est pas coutume je m'apprêtais à
développer la totalité les arguments que
mon collègue parisien vient de
développer ça me permettra d'être plus
court je voulais remercier roger
karoutchi de se rallier à la proposition
du rapporteur général parce que je pense
qu'il faut crantée quelque chose
effectivement qu'il n'ya rien eu au
départ dans le texte monsieur le
ministre
ça apparaissait quand même comme une
provocation alors vous nous donner un
début d'explication qui n'est pas très
convaincant c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire
le rapporteur général assemblée a fait
un effort je pense que et on fait
confiance à un autre rapporteur général
pour effectivement obtenir en cmp que
ces amendements soient retenus
définitivement je pense que c'est une
très bonne base de départ il faut la
crantée et puis nous verrons pour la
suite
sur le reste et sur les transports l'île
de france monsieur le ministre
j'espère au moins que tout le monde est
d'accord sur le constat ça ne peut pas
continuer comme ça je vais décevoir une
collègue ouzoulias mais pour les jeux
olympiques de 2024
on sait déjà par exemple que lille 16 et
17 du grand paris express ne seront pas
au rendez vous vous me direz quand on a
obtenu les jo à l'époque je le disais
déjà qu'on ne seraient pas maintenant
c'est confirmé alors si en plus devait
venir par là dessus se rajouter des
difficultés de financement enfin la
situation deviendrait absolument
catastrophique donc mes chers collègues
rallions nous aux amendements du
rapporteur général et faisons lui
confiance pour la cmp derrière et
je ne me rends vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président pour pas reprendre
ce qui vient d'être dit pas ce que je
vais aborder la situation de grand paris
express et notamment d'aline 17 et des
attentes que nous avons notamment du
délégué ministériel rol-tanguy pour la
suite d'un ce triangle de gonesse qui
conditionnait la réalisation de la ligne
donc c'est sûr c'est que la situation
des transports en ile-de-france entre la
ligne mais le charles de gaulle express
la ligne 17 pour le département du val
d'oise
nous avons les plus grandes incertitudes
sur la réalisation des équipes de ses
équipements de transport lourd qui sont
absolument nécessaires notamment dans le
cadre de la transition énergétique que
nous appelons tous deux non veut donc là
encore on sera vie comme je soutiendrai
évidemment ce qui a été définie défini
par le rapporteur général où va passer
au vote en essayant de le faire des
choses dans l'ordre
donc on commence par le 391 de monsieur
le rapporteur qui et pour qui est con
[Musique]
bon
c'est bien qu'ils aient contre qui
s'abstient je signale d'ailleurs que le
chant adoptés sont adoptés il y avait
deux amendements identiques par la même
occasion celui de messieurs mandelli
chaise éclaire un deuxième amendement
de monsieur le rapporteur général le 392
pied pour qui et contre qui s'obtient il
est adopté
troisième amendement de monsieur de
montgolfier mais identiques avec deux
autres qui seraient donc aussi adopté
qui est pour ces 2 393 qui et contre qui
s'abstient adopté ce qui veut dire que
tous les autres tombes dont celui de
monsieur ko dont ils étaient retirés et
et donc ils sont les trois adoptés et
tout est tombé
l'objectif de soutien au secteur qui
continue d'enregistrer de lourdes de
pertes
le gouvernement a décidé de prolonger et
d'élargir différentes aides au premier
rang desquels éligibilité au fonds de
solidarité
il a en effet été décidé que seront
désormais éligibles les entreprises de
certains secteurs comme l'hôtellerie la
restauration le sport etc qui réalisent
moins de 2 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires et qui emploient moins de 20
salariés le gouvernement a également
élargi le bénéfice de ce fonds aux mêmes
conditions aux entreprises de certains
secteurs qui dépendent fortement de ce
que je viens de citer et qui ont perdu
plus de 80 % de leur chiffre d'affaires
entre le 15 mars et le 15 mai en
première lecture l'assemblée à
l'assemblée nationale le gouvernement a
donc doté le fonds de 500 millions
d'euros supplémentaires pour autant ce
fonds continuent de souffrir d'un
certain nombre de lacunes qui nuisent à
notre son efficacité d'une part
l'assouplissement des critères
d'éligibilité ne s'applique que pour les
pertes de chiffres d'affaires subie au
mois de mai au mois de juin
et donc il importe aussi de prévoir la
reconduction du fonds pour la période
qui s'étend jusqu'au 31 décembre pour
les entreprises en difficulté
d'autre part pour les entreprises 40 est
un secteur d'activité qui sont lissées
dans le décret listez pardon dans le
décret cet assouplissement des critères
n'est effectif qu'en cas de baisse du
chiffre d'affaires de 80 % durant les
deux mois de confinement
par conséquent une entreprise qui aurait
subi 75 % de baisse de son chiffre
d'affaires est exclue de ce dispositif
spécifique
notre cellule
pme commerce artisanat salut vraiment
les l'assouplissement des critères
d'éligibilité qu'ont déjà été adoptée
mail considère que conditionner ce
bénéfice à une perte de chiffre
d'affaires de 80 % vide son contenu de
son contenu cette avancée par conséquent
nous demandons au gouvernement de
pérenniser le fonds de solidarité
jusqu'à la fin de l'année et surtout de
renoncer à une logique de soutien
sectoriel et d'opter pour une logique
qui est fondée sur les difficultés
réelles des entreprises par conséquent
nous vous proposons dans cet amendement
pour faire face à cette demande de
d'acter un fonds supplémentaire de 500
millions d'euros et je crois que c'est
en lien avec l'article 18 que présentera
le rapporteur tout à l'heure qui ne sera
pas sur cette logique sectorielle mais
qui sera sur une logique un peu plus
large si monsieur le rapporteur général
collègues présidente d'avoir soumis été
approché en effet l' approche
sectorielle qui présente un inconvénient
majeur c'est le risque d'oublier
certains secteurs parce que par
définition aux lorsque l'on vise un tel
et tel ou tel secteur
avec la diversité des activités
économiques est aujourd'hui un vrai
toutes les activités économiques sont
touchés le risque c'est de laisser des
trous dans le dispositif est d'avoir une
entreprise qui reste au bord du chemin
et on verra toutes les difficultés qu'il
y a notamment à définir les activités
lors de l'article 18 le gagnant a publié
vous l'avez vu une liste de l'entreprise
avec lé code ape on a eu un peu ce débat
cette nuit et c'était évidemment
extrêmement difficile de viser
l'ensemble des situations et il ya une
deuxième approche celle qui vient d'être
exprimées l'instant qu'il approche
globale qui vise à voir des dispositifs
qu'ils soient puissants qu'ils soient
prorogés dans le temps et qui permettent
de viser l'essentiel et toutes les
situations y compris celles qu'on a
auxquelles on n'aurait pas pensé par
l'approché tauriel donc vous souvenez
coopérer faire que le sénat avait voté
la majorité sénatoriale a voté un
abondement des crédits pour le fonds de
solidarité
moi je pense que cet amendement est
bienvenu parce qu'il permettra d'une
part de couvrir des secteurs qui sont
pas couverts et également de proroger
dispositif je vois que
l'activité n'a pas redémarré elle est
extrêmement difficile pour certains
secteurs voire à l'arrêt total pour
d'autres et il est important
d'ores et déjà d'entériner la
prolongation du dispositif qui
fonctionne directement occitane avis
favorable dans cet amendement qui est
bienvenu merci monsieur ministre madame
la présidente
le gouvernement considère que
l'essentiel des attentes de madame la
présidente prima trouve une solution
peuvent trouver une solution par voie
réglementaire pour ce qui concerne
l'éligibilité les critères de référence
c'est la raison de l'avis défavorable au
delà des questions de répartition de
crédit la logique du gouvernement
aujourd'hui est de privilégier une
approche sectorielle que vous contestez
je l'entends ce qui donne une deuxième
raison de donner un avis défavorable à
la partition crédit par conséquence même
si nous aurons l'occasion tout à l'heure
de revenir sur ce sujet l'article 18 si
monsieur qui vous avez la parole merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je vais
soutenir ce très bon amendement
d'autant plus que j'en suis signataire
puisque c'est son nom mais c'est le
rapport que nous avons co rédigé avec
anne chat larcher et serge babary moi je
vous le dit monsieur le ministre
depuis le début je pense que le fonds de
solidarité est une bonne chose
ce qui a permis d'éviter des fermetures
de petites entreprises de commerçants
d'artisans
ça a permis de ne pas licencier doublé
avec le chômage partiel pour ça que moi
je pense qu'il n'y a pas que dans le
secteur saisonniers ou il faut prolonger
le chômage partiel on a tout un débat
sur le chômage partiel longue durée
maintenant et je pense qu'il faut autant
de l'activité que le temps passé en
activité miser sur la formation et c'est
important
par exemple on peut avoir des accords
d'entreprise 60% au travail 40% en
formation payé 100% c'est mieux je crois
que des accords sont en train de se
développer partout notamment
l'aéronautique
le ministre le maire avait dit qu'il y
avait un accord d'assurance safran dans
sa fronde payer 90 % mais bon et donc le
fonds de solidarité est la bonne
solution
c'est pas maintenant qu'il faut
s'arrêter sinon c'est dans les mois à
venir où les commerçants les artisans et
les pme vont se retrouver en très grande
difficulté on peut pas s'arrêter au bord
du gué donc il faut continuer y compris
je pense que pour certains secteurs il
faudra le prolonger jusqu'en juin 2021
mais bon ils ont qu'à arrêtons-nous ans
au 31 décembre et on aura le débat lors
du plf 2021 et je pense que la question
des plans sectoriels et on l'a vu tout
au long de l'après midi d'hier hier soir
et encore ce matin on en oublie et on en
oubliera et il y aura encore des trous
dans la raquette et en plus vous avez
une question c'est que sur un certain
nombre de plans sectoriels je prends par
exemple l'aéronautique ou l'automobile
en sont exclues massivement les sous
traitants c'est ça la question
aujourd'hui par exemple sur le plan
aéronautique c'est le big four qui
ramassent tout et les 300 entreprises
sous traitantes en sont exclus donc moi
je pense que c'est la bonne solution on
propose 500 millions d'euros c'est
évidemment un énorme engagement mais
c'est aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut et puis
après on aura le débat en deux ans au
plf 2021 pour le continuer je vous
remercie madame la présidente
merci chers collègues y at il d'autres
demandes d'explications de vote
non je n'en vois pas donc nous je mets
au voile amendement 491 rectifié qu'une
caisse avec un avis favorable de la
commission et un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour et qui est
contre
oui qui est qui et contre qui s'abstient
il est adopté
nous passons à l'amendement 21 rectifié
bis madame dumas oui merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur mes chers collègues je
voudrais revenir sur le sujet des
intermittents du spectacle mais par
rapport à leur employeur en effet malgré
le recours aux aides déployés par les
pouvoirs publics pour surmonter les
effets de la crise sanitaire les
entreprises qui emploient des
intermittents du spectacle ont été
particulièrement touchés par les
conséquences économiques financières et
sociales de la pandémie covit 19
il apparaît que ses employeurs doivent
dans ce contexte difficile versées à la
caisse des congés spectacle les
cotisations de congés payés sur les
indemnités d'activité partielle or un
très grand nombre d'employeurs éprouvent
des difficultés à assumer le règlement
de ces cotisations sur l'indemnité
d'activité partielle dès lors la caisse
des congés spectacle pourrait elle même
ne plus pouvoir procéder au paiement des
indemnités auprès de ses quelque 170
mille bénéficiaires dans un contexte où
ils ont besoin vous le savez plus que
jamais de protection en conséquence
l'amendement que je défends vise à
abonder la ligne budgétaire de prise en
charge du dispositif exceptionnel de
chômage partiel à la suite de la crise
sanitaire afin de pouvoir accompagner
ces entreprises dans le paiement des
cotisations dues à la caisse des congés
spectacle c'était des d'ailleurs
d'autant plus indispensable que c'est
tout l'édifice social élaboré pour les
intermittents du spectacle qui pourrait
être ébranlée par la crise créditée d'un
montant de 20 millions d'euros il sera
ouvert aux employeurs susvisé je
voudrais préciser mes chers collègues
que ce montant de 20 millions se fonde
sur des estimations de la caisse des
congés spectacle à propos des
cotisations dues sur les indemnités
d'activité partielle depuis le mois de
mars 2020 merci monsieur le rapporteur
général
un amendement 21 rectifié bis oui donc
je comprends la problématique évoquée
par d'autres collègues mais j'aimerais
avoir la confirmation du maintenant
parce que l'analyse en est différente
lorsque lorsqu'il y a des le chômage
partiel est bien sûr les emplois des
entreprises qui emploient des
intermittents du spectacle sont
évidemment éligibles au chômage partiel
et dans ce cas là il n'y a pas de
cotisation parce qu'il s'agit de revenu
de remplacement
donc je ne comprends pas très bien
pourquoi il faudrait prendre en compte
créer un crédit pour prendre en charge
le dispositif afin d'accompagner la
prise en charge dès que des centres
congés payés normalement c'est un revenu
de remplacement qui est pris en charge
par l'état et les cotisations sont pris
en charge par l'état mais peut-être que
le gouvernement peut nous confirmer
l'analyse
auquel cas ça serait si l'année visite
est confirmée une demande de retrait
monsieur le ministre je confirme
l'analyse madame la présidente et
j'ajoute que le dispositif proposé par
madame la sénatrice on parle et
redondant avec le maintien des droits
actes et jusqu'au 31 autres 2021 ondées
favre à madame dumas bien je prends acte
de vos réponses
en fait les discussions qui ont lieu
avec les intermittents du spectacle et
notamment leur employeur surtout ne
conduisait pas à ce type d'arguments
donc bon j'en prends acte et je retire
l'amant non merci nous avons maintenant
deux amants de l'offre dans l'objet
d'une discussion commune
le premier 1000 l'amendement 1071
présenté par le gouvernement
monsieur le ministre merci madame la
présidente il s'agit d'un amendement de
crédit qui vise à ouvrir 50 millions
d'euros pour permettre de répondre aux
augmentations de coûts des bourses sur
critères sociaux mais aussi pour
financer
l'annnonce du premier ministre de ticket
de restaurant universitaire pour les
étudiants boursiers pour permettre des
repas 1 euro vous merci monsieur le
rapporteur général favorable favorable
el jazouli à ce qu'il présente et c'est
l'amendement 863 merci madame la
présidente mme c'est donc monsieur le
monsieur le ministre
dans un premier temps monsieur mise
votre gouvernement nous avait proposé
150 millions et comme vous l'avez dit
très justement est tout à fait
honnêtement l'intervention du premier
ministre a rajouté 50 millions dans dans
la balance pour permettre au cnous de
satisfaire l'engagement de votre
gouvernement c'est-à-dire abaissé à 1
euro le coût de la restauration
universitaire pour les étudiants
boursiers
néanmoins néanmoins je vous le dis ça ne
suffira pas ça ne suffira pas nous
avions au sein de la commission de la
culture sous l'autorité de notre
collègue stéphane pieds-noirs réaliser
un audit de la situation du cnous
c'était en mai je pense qu'aujourd'hui
elle a dû encore s'aggraver le cnous
nous disait il ya deux mois qu'ils
avaient un déficit un déficit de
trésorerie de 200 millions cirque ce que
vous apportez la avec vos 200 millions
150 plus 50
c'est juste ce qu'il faut pour couvrir
le déficit actuel du cnous qui bien vide
évidemment va continuer à augmenter
jusqu'à la rentrée de septembre
donc la mesure de monsieur castex avec
laquelle je suis absolument favorable
n'est pas financée par le dispositif que
vous nous proposez c'est pour ça que
dans un amendement qui est qu'il est
qu'ils suivent en 863 moi je je je
propose non seulement de combler le
déficit actuel du cnous de son million
médard a ajouté 50 millions ce qui est
exactement le ce que ce que vous venez
d'évoquer c'est à dire que ça permet en
effet de financer les engagements du
premier ministre donc si vous voulez
être cohérent chers collègues vous
monsieur miss il faudrait plutôt voter
mon amendement pas ce qui permettra en
effet de satisfaire les engagements du
gouvernement pas votre amendement merci
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
je crois que ces deux amendements sur
discussion commune alors je vais dire à
chaque jour suffit sa peine je suis bien
consciente qu'il faudrait plus mail à
l'ouverture du gouvernement et
l'abondement de crédits permet de
répondre sans doute pas que
partiellement la situation dommage de
donner les fables la vie du l'amendement
du gouvernement
donc je pense que si vous êtes
partiellement sans doute satisfait je
vous invite à vous y rallier
merci donc vous demander de me demande
de retrait monsieur très bien monsieur
le ministre monsieur bargeton merci mr
la présidente bon on peut toujours voir
les verres à moitié vide on peut les
voir à moitié plein je vais pas abuser
du temps de parole je voudrais dire que
notre groupe est particulièrement fier
de voter cet amendement qui correspond à
un engagement qui a été pris a été
rappelé par le premier ministre c'était
une demande ancienne des associations
étudiantes leur pas un euro de la fage
de l'unef et d'autres d'ailleurs qui
était de pouvoir avoir un repas 1 euros
pour les étudiants boursiers 715 milles
sont concernés dès le 1er septembre
je pense que c'est une avancée concrète
pour elles et eux qui font la souligner
je rappelle que cela va avec la
revalorisation des bourses et j'y ajoute
un autre
une autre disposition qui est l'aide
pour les titulaires d'apl de moins de 25
ans qui vont avoir un soutien de 200
euros et ses huit cent mille jeunes de
moins de 25 ans qui sont concernés donc
je voulais souligner cet amendement cet
engagement est bien sûr nous le voterons
merci beaucoup merci monsieur ozu dias
merci mais un présidente monsieur le
ministre
chers collègues je je pense sincèrement
que il faut que vous ayez chers
collègues une vision juste de la
situation économique catastrophique dans
lesquelles se trouvent les universités
françaises pour la rentrée de septembre
vous avez bien compris avec les
résultats exceptionnels du beh il ya
cent mille bacheliers supplémentaires ce
qui représente environ 40 mille
étudiants supplémentaires à accueillir
dans les universités au 1er septembre
la conférence des présidents
d'université de façon consensuelle
consensuelle et en accord avec la
commission de la culture de notre de
notre sénat estime que simplement pour
faire la rentrée et accueillir les 40000
à 50000 et 50 mille étudiants
supplémentaires
il faudrait 250 à 300 millions d'euros
la conférence des présidents
d'université je la cite nous dit nous
sommes arrivés à la limite du système et
elle demande de façon très solennelle
une réunion d'urgence aujourd'hui au
plus haut sommet de l'état
nous en sommes là donc je vous le redis
les 200 millions qui viennent d'apporter
ne suffiront pas c'est une goutte au par
rapport aux besoins essentiels des
universités pour pouvoir faire la
rentrée
sinon elle n'y arriveront pas merci il
n'y a pas d'autres demandes de parole je
vais donc mettre aux voix l'amendement
1071 avec donc un amendement du
gouvernement avec un avis favorable de
la commission qui est pour et qui est
contre
il est adopté et l'amendement 863 est
donc satisfait nous passons à
l'amendement 527 qui n'est pas soutenue
6 il est soutenu monsieur le ministre
non non vous ne pouvez pas que monsieur
de la est le seul signataire
nous passons à l'amendement 113 oui
madame taux de ville au sein de la
mission recherche et enseignement
supérieur le présent amendement vise à
annuler 600 millions d'euros de crédits
pour le programme recherche spatiale et
à ouvrir donc 300 millions pour le
programme formation supérieure
universitaire et 300 millions d'euros
pour le programme vie étudiante
l'ensemble des dispositions prises pour
le projet de loi de finances
rectificative sont en faveur du soutien
à l'économie aux entreprises pourtant la
crise sanitaire a eu d'importantes
conséquences sur d'autres points
d'autres pans de la société en
particulier l'enseignement supérieur
ainsi des étudiants ne disposant pas
d'outils numériques n'ont pu suivre
l'ensemble des cours
accéder aux bases de données des
universités ou échanger avec les
enseignants et les autres étudiants les
universités ont vu ainsi se creuser un
déficit de 1 % dans leur budget or aucun
engagement n'a été pris à ce sujet par
le ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
et de la recherche concernant un
possible accompagnement financier depuis
ces étudiants les plus précaires ont été
durement touchés par la crise sanitaire
et cette situation risque de perdurer
avec la difficulté pour certains de
trouver des emplois pour l'été
c'est pourquoi il convient d'aider ces
étudiants en augmentant les bourses qui
leur sont destinés merci monsieur le
rapporteur général défavorable
monsieur le ministre défavorable je vais
donc mettre aux voix l'amendement 113
avec deux avis défavorables pied pour
qui et contre il n'est pas adopté nous
passons à l'amendement 862 me fuel
yassim la présidente subissent mes chers
collègues c'est un débat que nous avons
eu déjà donc je vais je vais l'abrégé
pour limiter à l'essentiel
je suis tout à fait satisfait du
consensus auquel nous savons nous sommes
arrivés dans la discussion du précédent
amendement le gouvernement est ici la
représentation nationale estime
absolument indispensable de financer la
prolongation des contrats doctoraux nous
sommes tous d'accord c'est une question
de survie pour la science française
là où nous différons notamment avec le
rapporteur général
c'est sur l'urgence de la disposition
vous considérez et je comprends votre
votre raisonnement que ces moyens
supplémentaires pour être mis dans le
cadre de la loi de finances 2021 je ne
le pense pas et je vais vous expliquer
en deux mots pourquoi parce que il
s'agit de contrats de trop et dans la
réalisation d'une thèse d'une thèse de
doctorat vous avez une obligation délais
vous avez l'obligation en sciences dures
de faire votre thèse de doctorat en deux
ans dans les sciences humaines un petit
1 un petit peu plus et c'est de l'est
est fondamental pour l'obtention de
plot mais aussi pour la validation
internationale du diplôme une thèse qui
est fait en deux ans une fête qui ne
t'est ce qu'elle fait en trois ans
quatre ans n'a pas la pinte valeur
quelle que soit la mention que vous
allez obtenir
donc on peut pas différer cette
nécessaire prolongation des contrats qu
de trop à une date qui seraient trop
lointaine en 2029
1 ce que si on vote dans le budget 2021
ça pourra pas se mettre en place avant
le printemps 2021 c'est dire que vous
fait perdre une année entière de
scolarité aux étudiants
je vous heureux je vous le redis ça ça
peut mettre en danger la qualité de leur
diplôme donc nous sommes d'accord sur la
nécessité de financer ces contrats
doctoraux je vous le redis si encore une
fois je crois qu'il faut le faire dans
l'extrême urgence et permettent la mise
en place de ses moyens dès la rentrée de
septembre
c'est la seule solution pour sauver un
certain nombre de thèses de doctorat et
notamment et notamment des recherches
sur sur la côte vide
nous nous on nous en avons besoin mais
je développe le sujet dans l'amendement
qui suis je vous remercie
merci mon général je vous ai cité la
circulaire de juin 2020 et l'analyse
qu'on en avait cédé dire à la fois
l'engagement du gouvernement de payer
sur la fin de gestion / 2021 donc je
reste à cette analyse donc deux avis
défavorables
même avis pour le gouvernement je vais
donc mettre aux voix l'amendement 862
avec deux avis défavorables qui est pour
et qui est contre il n'est pas adoptée
nous passons à l'amendement 864 je suis
augias merci dans la présidente monsieur
le ministre
là il s'agit d'un amendement qui va
abonder les moyens de la recherche
publique et notamment des grans de deux
grands opérateurs cnrc et inserm
chers collègues il faut que vous
compreniez bien dans quelle situation
paradoxale se trouve
la recherche française nos collègues
allemands par exemple pour ne prendre
que cet exemple ont investi à hauteur de
4 milliards sur la recherche médicale
sur la recherche d'un vaccin sur la
recherche de thérapies nous dans notre
pays le ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur la recherche pour l'instant
n'a mobilisé que 50 millions 50 millions
sur ses réserves si requis il n'y a pas
eu d'abondement par le budget de l'état
du budget du ministère l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche pour faire de
la recherche médicale c'est évidemment
absolument catastrophique
nous sommes dans une situation où nos
citoyens demandent à la science de leur
proposer demain pour sortir de cette
pandémie des solutions thérapeutiques et
un vaccin or not pays n'investit pas sur
cette recherche par ailleurs je voudrais
souligner la pourrit de votre
gouvernement qui nous explique qui va
investir très largement dans la
recherche 28 milliards en dix ans et qui
est incapable l'année de la pandémie de
mettre quelques sous sur la recherche
pour l'obtention de thérapie et de
vaccins c'est complètement absurde
si vous estimez comme la ministre de la
recherche que j'ai entendu hier à 8h43
srna radio nationale qui nous a dit que
l'investissement de la recherche était
une nécessité absolue
pourquoi ne pas commencer en 2020 année
de la pandémie
pourquoi reporter à plus tard quelque
chose dont nous avons besoin maintenant
c'est tout à fait essentiel et je
regarde que dans votre projet de loi
rectificatif vous consacrez 85 millions
à la recherche aéronautique et 30
millions pour bpi france et notamment 10
millions sur les batteries donc là vous
mettez de l'argent sur la recherche et
je suis désolé moi j'aime beaucoup
l'aéronautique et les batteries mais
c'est pas ce qui va nous sauver
face à la pandémie donc je ne comprends
pas pourquoi vous faites le choix
politique de réinjecter presque 100
millions d'euros sur des recherches qui
elles peuvent être différents 2000
et que vous ne mettez pas maintenant en
2020 des choses qui sont indispensables
pour faire face à la pandémie
merci merci monsieur le rapporteur
général je pense que la question
s'adresse au gouvernement plus que
rapporteur général à vis du gouvernement
qui va vous le donne et monsieur le
ministre le gouvernement va présenter va
examiner la loi de programmation de la
recherche sont 400 millions d'euros par
an dès l'année prochaine nous
redéployons des crédits cette année je
puis vous assurer monsieur le sénateur
que les équipes de recherche françaises
sont à pied d'oeuvre est accompagné par
les daims contrairement à ce que vous
avez dit défavorable
quelle est la vie donc de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur général demande
de retrait profit en attendant la loi de
programmation pour voir si oui merci
madame la présidente
écoutez je demande de retrait en
attendant la loi de programmation
alors qu'il ya urgence mais elle a très
bien expliqué monsieur le ministre nous
dit que la recherche française va très
bien circulez ya rien à voir
enfin il me semble qu'il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de mobilisation beaucoup
d'inquiétude dans le milieu de la
recherche française et cela depuis de
nombreuses années mais ça va en
s'amplifiant
et malgré les annonces justement du
projet de loi recherche donc ne dit pas
que tout va bien parce que je crois que
la situation allait elle et elle est pas
très favorable
les chercheurs sont inquiets et qu'il
faudrait répondre tout de suite à
l'urgence
merci monsieur elias pour explication de
vote
monsieur monsieur le ministre
merci dans la présente monsieur le
ministre votre réponse fait peser un
doute sur la sincérité des objectifs
quant à la loi de programmation la
recherche
si vous êtes incapable l'année du pain
des dieux de la pandémie en 2020 de
mettre des moyens pour la recherche d'un
vaccin
comment vous faire confiance sur la
volonté réelle de votre gouvernement
d'investir massivement dans la recherche
pour les années suivantes
moi j'aimerais citer le professeur
mattei président de l'académie nationale
dé
de médecine qui nous dit il y à une
urgence immédiate à rémédier au déficit
majeur du financement public de la
recherche médicale
c'est maintenant qu'il faut le faire il
est incompréhensible que l'allemagne
investissent à hauteur de 4 milliards 4
milliards chers collègues et que nous
nous soyons incapables dans le cadre de
cette loi de finances rectificatif ou
d'injecter ne serait-ce que 150 millions
là ce que ce que vous faites c'est que
vous condamnez la france à attendre d'un
grand groupe pharmaceutique la mise au
point d'un vaccin
et après nous irons commander 2 0 et
demandé pardon à ce grand groupe
pharmaceutique l'espoir de pouvoir le
acheté des doses parce que vous avez
compris que sanofi ira au plus offrant
et il n'ira pas à la france parce que
justement la france ne met pas d'argent
dans la recherche
aujourd'hui l'objectif est il est là il
ya une mise en concurrence des états
international sur la recherche
donc ce que ce que vous mettez pas ici
comme argent c'est c'est une position
défavorable pour la france dans la
négociation de la ccia du futur vaccin
je peux vous assurer que sanofi rats au
plus offrant qui ira vers l'allemagne
qui met 4 milliards vers les états unis
et pas vers la france qui met 0 vous
envoyez un message extrêmement négatif à
toute la population française qui attend
aujourd'hui de sortir par la science et
par le haut de cette pandémie avec un
espoir thérapeutique un espoir de
vaccins ce héros est catastrophique
merci monsieur l'abbé ni vous avez la
parole
oui merci monsieur mais merci madame la
présidente pardon sur le ministre chers
collègues concernant cet amendement est
notre collègue à bord d'un un sujet
particulièrement important on dépose en
cet amendement puisque on le dit chaque
quand on examine la mission sinon
j'espère y auraient elles recherchent
même 6 cette mission fait partie des en
masse financière parmi les plus
importantes
mais concernant toutes les déclarations
qui ont été faites notamment par le
présent la république le premier
ministre monsieur edouard philippe
l'actuel premier ministre le ministre de
la santé etc
donc on donnons les moyens des moyens de
recherches pour le vaccin sûr quand même
des lutter contre cette crise sanitaire
essayer de trouver des solutions
bon on est en loi de finances
rectificative on connaît la la
complexité des finances publiques
mais c'est vrai qu'on dit partout layton
l'enseignement supérieur cette mission
les opérateurs qui interviennent et qui
sont cités dans l'objet de cet
amendement qui est particulièrement
aussi détaillé pédagogique donc le tout
c'est de trouver vraiment en termes
d'efficacité des résultats est donné les
moyens à leur recherche de ton plus
l'état participe mais aussi les
collectivités territoriales qui
soutiennent aussi l'enseignement
supérieur et la recherche
donc je dirais part je soutiendrai cet
amendement merci madame de khomeiny
merci madame la présidente
écoutez moi aussi je soutiendrai cet
amendement parce que nous sommes
suffisamment plein de tout ce qui n'a
pas été fait pendant pendant cette
période de co vide jusqu'à présent on a
des regrets et il faut arrêter d'avoir
des regrets et se dire qu'on a mis tout
ce qu'il fallait pour pour ne plus avoir
de regrets et se dire comment on a fait
le maximum donc je soutiendrai cet
amendement merci monsieur la table et
vous dire que notre groupe sera
également cet amendement qui est précis
intéressant merci il n'y a pas d'autres
demandes de oui merci dans la brise
aussi je tiens cette maman j'ai côtoyé
et je côtoie encore beaucoup de
chercheurs est vraiment ils ont besoin
on avait une place de leader sur le plan
mondial on le perd petit à petit on
parle beaucoup de de santé personnalisés
de traitements innovants
il faut donner aux chercheurs le moyen
de trouver des nouveaux traitements
intéressant merci madame tellement corps
police madame roulez vous avez la parole
oui j'ai soutenu tout à l'heure le
l'amendement sur les thèses et le fait
qu'il fallait l'alimenter évidemment et
nous allons aussi soutenir cet
amendement
merci bien je ne vois pas d'autres
demandent mes paroles je vais donc
mettre aux voix l'amendement 864 avec
une demande de retrait de la commission
un avis défavorable du gouvernement qui
est pour et qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté nous
passons à l'amendement 169 rectifié
madame son logo
merci madame la présidente l'action 1 du
programme 231 vie étudiante financer ces
aides directes pour les étudiantes dans
ce cadre la loi de finances pour 2020 a
prévu de transférer 4 millions d'euros à
bp france afin de financer son fonds de
garantie prêts étudiants ce dispositif a
un effet levier important puisque en
2019 3000 étudiants ont ainsi pu obtenir
un prêt garantis à 70% par l'état pour
un total de 24 millions de prêts soit
une moyenne de 8000 euros par près
l'enveloppent augmenté pour 2020 à 4
millions d'euros reste insuffisante
puisque la bpi réclamé 5 et million et
demi de crédit annuel afin d'atteindre
un montant total de 100 millions d'euros
de prêts cela permettrait aux banques de
commercialiser ce produit plus largement
et plus longtemps
l'enveloppé d'autant plus insuffisante
cette année que les conséquences
économiques de la crise que nous
traversons les seront inévitablement des
traces dans le budget des familles les
plus modestes
j'ajoute puisque j'ai écouté avec
attention ce que disait notre collègue
aux oulias qu'il y aura quarante mille
bacheliers de plus et qu'il faudra
pouvoir venir aider tous ces jeunes à
accéder à la formation qu'ils souhaitent
obtenir alors d'une part on entend
beaucoup le gouvernement nous expliquer
que la jeunesse sera l'enjeu majeur du
post coup vite donc il faut que nous
soyons à ce rendez-vous et d'autre part
le posco vie nous l'aborderons aussi
avec des compétences nous avons besoin
de compétences il faut qu' aucun jeune
se retrouve sur le bord de la route
simplement parce qu'il n'a pas pu
accéder à l'enseignement supérieur pour
deux pour des raisons matérielles
donc voilà c'est un amendement de ma
collègue catherine fournier que je suis
fier de présenter
merci et je vais solliciter de la vie du
rapport du rapporteur général pour la
commission
merci monsieur mais ma vie très bien
dans ce métro voilà mon nom 169
rectifier avec deux avis défavorables
qui est pour et qui est contre il n'est
pas adopté je vais mettre voir
l'ensemble du projet de loi de finances
rectificative pour 2020 il y at il des
demandes d'explications de vote
monsieur k dick ainsi monsieur le
président je me disent mes chers
collègues
notre collègue bernard delcros l'a dit
en ouverture de la discussion générale
la très grande majorité du groupe union
centriste adoptera ce troisième budget
rectificatif dans sa version modifiée
par le sénat pour ma part je suis très
inquiet devant les sombres perspectives
qui s'ouvrent pour notre pays je reste
perplexe sur la stratégie suivie cette
fuite en avant budgétaire à laquelle
nous nous livrons emballement du déficit
et de l'endettement public
après avoir épuisé le présent on dévore
à l'avenir aurait sûrement dit le
célèbre économiste frédéric bastiat avec
un nouveau déficit de plus de 225
milliards d'euros s'ajoutant à une dette
elle même qu la salle nous engageons
notre responsabilité collective à
l'égard des générations futures
curieux paradoxe j'entends de tout pas
au bord s'est levé le mot souveraineté
mais en même temps nous nous mettons
entre les mains de créanciers étrangers
aucun de nous sur ces bancs ne peut
s'exempter d'un examen de conscience
il suffit de suivre le dérouleur des
amendements pour voir que quelque chose
ne va pas la dépense par est incontrôlée
on injecte des crédits budgétaires comme
on injecte un médicament qui soulage et
permet de passer la nuit
mais ne règle rien confronté à sa pire
récession depuis 1917
l'économie française est au bord de la
débâcle certains pour financer tous les
plans marshall ont une solution faire
payer les riches
l'idée à elle pour elle la force de la
simplicité
mais les faiblesses de la démagogie
cette démagogie qui consiste à voter
contre le budget au motif qu'il ne
serait jamais assez dépensiers comme on
l'a vu à l'assemblée nationale l'issue
serait la ruine pour tous d'autres
cèdent aux mirages de
l'interventionnisme mû par une
conception paternaliste de l'économie il
croit pouvoir guider les comportements à
travers des baisses ciblées de
cotisations sociales et de fiscalité à
vouloir jouer les mécanos ont créé un
monde fait de complexité qui entravent
notre économie ce chemin rendre à la
france dépendante d'autres pays plus
agile plus performant par solidarité
dans l'épreuve
je voterai ce texte mais je suis
convaincu qu'une autre voie est possible
la france ne sera sera pas sans
affronter ses propres faiblesses et sans
revoir son fonctionnement profondeur
cela passe par la simplification de nos
réglementations et de nos impôts je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues monsieur ben asher
pour explication de vote juste avoir le
ministre a donc adopté un budget avec
226 milliards de déficit public
eh bien j'ai une solution qui plairait
beaucoup à beaucoup de monde il suffit
de doubler le taux de toutes les
impositions car j'ai beaucoup entendu
d'augmentation de taxes pour réduire le
déficit à zéro
voilà car les recettes fiscales de ce
budget correspondent exactement aux
déficits donc c'est une solution que je
propose pour réduire la dette non plus
sérieusement ce des voix bien à quelle
situation où on en est on va dépenser
deux fois plus que ce que l'on a deux
fois plus que ce que l'on a de manière
courante de manière courante
c'est pas un budget d'investissement
convient de faire c'est pas le budget de
la relance et la règle d'or ne
s'applique pas et c'est bien cela
peut-être la leçon qu'il faudra tirer de
cette crise de sa dette qui explose
que l'on cantonne ou qu'on ne condamne
pas il ya là un problème monstrueux
devant nous alors c'est vrai que ces
appels et faire un peu bizarre il a été
fait par un gouvernement adopté par un
autre car nous avons changé de premier
ministre
entre son dépôt initial et puis ce qu'il
sera après alors peut-être que ça change
pas grand chose en même temps mais en
même temps entre le 14 juillet et le 15
juillet entre les annonces du président
de la république et celle du premier
ministre et rémi féraud l'a rappelé tout
à l'heure il y à bien des différences
alors on est très embêté sur ce budget
on sait qu'on ne peut pas s'en passer
mais en même temps on sait qu' on n'est
pas au bout avec cela et dans le débat
on a vu plein de sujets manqué la
culture a été largement évoqué l'emploi
on le sait très bien
mais il ya encore plein d'autres qui
sont créées par des sujets que vous avez
créé tout à l'heure on a parlé des
attaques d'habitations on voit bien que
le sujet n'est pas épuisé j'en termine
pour j'aurais simplement qu'on remercie
le président de séance qui fait qu'on
est là à cette heure ci en train de
finir je vous répondre merci merci chers
collègues
la parole est à monsieur ferro pour
explication de vote
merci monsieur le président et merci
aussi pour la conduite de nos débats qui
finit nous permettent en effet de finir
à une heure raisonnable
je trouve que l'explication de vote
olivier cadic et de jérôme bascher sont
assez illustrative parce que finalement
vous critiquez ce budget trop dépensier
créé entre autres déficits mais vous le
voter ce qui me paraît être une nouvelle
preuve que ce n'est pas un budget de
combat
ça n'est pas un budget de combat face à
la crise c'est un budget c'est pas le
minimum qu'on peut faire c'est davantage
mais qui n'est pas à la hauteur de ce
qu'il faudrait faire pour vraiment
sortir de la crise il eu d'ailleurs les
chiffres du sénat lui même pas ceux du
groupe socialiste et républicain montre
que ce ne sont pas 500 milliards mais 60
milliards d'euros qui sont dépensés face
à cette crise par la france et que cette
représente 2,6 pour cent du pib beaucoup
moins que la plupart des autres pays
comparables alors nous mêmes nous
regrettons particulièrement le fait que
ne soient pas prises en compte un
certain nombre de secteurs
en tout cas pas suffisamment pris en
compte et dans tous ces secteurs la
culture évidemment est certainement le
grand oublié du ce budget les
collectivités locales sont pour le
moment dans une grande incertitude est
largement mise à contribution face à la
crise sans que nous sachions
véritablement quelles seront leurs
perspectives
après sept années 2020 et puis ensuite
les les deux grands mots qui sont
absents des mesures qui sont prises et
qui sont tout aussi absente après les
amendements votés au sénat c'est d'abord
la justice sociale parce que toutes les
impôts et toutes les taxes ne se valent
pas cher jérôme bascher il y a une vraie
volonté en effet de ne pas mettre
davantage à contribution les plus aisés
face à cette crise et c'est un grand
désaccord une grande divergence entre
nous et puis ensuite en matière
d'écologie
j'espère que nous pourrons vite mettre
en oeuvre au moins une partie des
recommandations de la conférence de la
convention citoyenne parce que en parler
c'est bien mais le faire c'est mieux et
ça n'est pas en tout cas dans ce peuple
dans ce projet de loi de finances
rectificative que nous voyons ces
conclusions mises en oeuvre donc pour
toutes ces raisons et de manière très
logique
notre groupe votera contre le projet de
loi de finances une fois discuté par
notre assemblée
merci chers collègues chefs va tabler
pour explication de vote
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
achevons enfin l'examen de ce troisième
projet de finances rectificative il clôt
une séance budgétaire hors norme
entamée fin mars avec le projet de loi
de ratification en fait rouge j'ai trois
textes
une seule priorité sauver notre économie
et nos entreprises face un choc
salutaire sans aucun précédent notre
histoire
au fur et à mesure on pu constater
l'ampleur cette crise qui n'a pas fini
nous sévirons pas un panda société n'y a
échappé entreprises salariés
collectivités et je dirais si vous
voulez
cette crise n'est pas finie elle ne fait
que commencer c'est vrai comme certains
l'ont dit beaucoup dépenses ont été
faites mais je pense que nous devons
prendre un peu de hauteur
on a juste mesure du test nous avons que
nous avons voté je pense aux armes en
tout ce qui était destiné aux uns aux
autres et dans ce temps très difficiles
notre site est engagé et je crois que
tous ensemble enfin travail de fond a
diversement des idées différentes
mais pour le bien quand même de ce pays
et moi ce que je voulais dire
aujourd'hui j'étais très surpris de ces
chants jeux de très forts de cette
c'est vrai qu'elle ait des choses qui ne
sais pas mais c'est quand même important
de votre ce texte joly y aura quand même
des gens qui sont en difficulté et pour
certains autres groupes les indépendants
votre voix ce texte et je remercie
monsieur le rapporteur de la commission
des finances
et vous même d'avoir réussi à terminer
dans les temps parce qu'il ya urgence
pour notre pays merci cher collègue
monsieur bargeton merci monsieur le
président merci aussi la façon dont vous
avez présidé en lien d'ailleurs avec le
rapporteur général qui nous a permis de
terminer dans de bonnes conditions dès
ce soir nous allons voter notre groupe
ce plfr ont certes il a été modifié par
le sénat mais c'est un vote qui nous
permet de préparer la cmp dont nous
souhaitons qu'elle soit conclusive
et donc s'il ya des amendements je me
suis parfois abstenus ou que je n'ai pas
voté ou pour lesquelles j'ai voté tout
ça ne préfigure pas de l'issue est donc
dans cette optique que nous ne nous le
voterons je note aussi d'ailleurs que le
sénat a voté les amendements du
gouvernement soffin je crois tous les
amendements déposés par le gouvernement
en disant qu'ils ont été déposés de
façon tardive ont été votées par la
majorité sénatoriale est donc évidemment
ça nous conduit aussi à voter ce texte
au fond ce texte faisait quoi ils
rechargent les crédits il le déploie des
plans sectoriels
il accroît l'apprentissage pour les
jeunes et il prévoit aussi un certain
nombre de choses notamment pour les plus
démunis d'entre nous notamment sur
l'hébergement d'urgence l'économie
générale du texte n'a pas été modifié
à l'issue de cet examen et cela nous
conduit à l'adopter j'ai deux nuances
par rapport à ce qui a été exprimé sur
les collectivités locales je rappellerai
qu'il ya quand même quatre milliards et
demi d'euros plus 500 millions sur la
mobilité qu'en 2009
oui qu'en 2009 il n'y avait pas eu de
plan pour les collectivités locales
au moment de la crise et que c'est la
première fois qu'il y a une garantie de
ressources qui est apportée enfin une
deuxième nuit ans vis-à-vis de la gauche
que j'assume ce n'est pas le moment
d'augmenter les impôts on peut avoir un
débat sur les
quel sur ce qui sera un rêve en 2022
mais encore une fois keynes nous
l'enseignent quand il y à une dépression
l'activité on ne baisse pas la dépense
publique et on n'augmente pas les
impositions parce que ça déprimerait
davantage l'activité
quand nous serons revenu à meilleure
fortune espérons que nous soyons revenus
mais meilleure fortune c'est à dire que
l'économie reparte et donc l'emploi
repart on verra ce qu'il convient de
faire au moment des grands débats
politiques qui nous attendent nous
sommes tous suspendus à l'europe ce soir
et en espérant que cela puisse aboutir
même s'il peut y avoir des inquiétudes
nous sommes tous suspendus à cela parce
que oui il ya derrière un pl f1 plf qui
devra traiter d'autres sujets pour la
relance notamment sur l'écologie sur la
culture ça a été un indiqué mais aussi
en tenant compte d'une articulation avec
ce que font nos partenaires européens
je vous remercie monsieur savoldelli
pour explication de vote
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues avant
d'avoir quelques réflexions politiques
jouer d'abord au nom de mon groupe
remercié l'ensemble du personnel du
sénat
quels que soient gérés dire leur métier
leurs fonctions ici au sein de du
travail et la vie de l'hémicycle parce
qu'on a des conditions vraiment
excellente
donc merci leur professionnalisme et
leur proximité avec l'ensemble des élus
on vient d'avoir c'est le troisième pôle
fr3 fz6 on est assez rigoureux on a eu
beaucoup de nos débats des débats
d'idées avec nos expériences les uns les
autres qui étaient des débats que nous
avons eus déjà les années précédentes
pour beaucoup et quand on a posé par
exemple de question il faut qu'on voie
totalement notre système de fiscalité
notre débat vient de montrer la queue il
n'y a pas de roue de secours au logis
tiki
sont les logiques économiques et
financières certes de la majorité
actuelle mais des majorités précédente
on l'a pas la roue de secours là on est
en face à ce que j'ai pu dire peut-être
le terme était discutable on est devant
un cocktail explosif mes chers collègues
les indicateurs sociaux aux indicateurs
économiques les tensions internationales
enfin voila je pense sincèrement avec de
l'humilité aussi et modestement je pense
que nous sommes pas au niveau des des
enjeux et des défis qui sont qui sont
devant nous et avec ce qui peut être la
singularité de la france dans ce débat
là il n'y a pas grand chose qui a changé
y compris il ya des insolences excusez
moi au moment où on va voter là ont fini
ensemble les cinq premières fortunes
dispose l'équivalent du patrimoine du
déficit de 2020 cinq familles dispose de
la somme qui fait le déficit de 2020
d'envoyer il ya quelque chose qui est
quand même il ya quand même une à une à
une insolence qui étaient devant nous un
président de la république qui certes il
ya les mesures sur notre collègue
bargeton kyi qui défend sa politique
c'est normal
enfin c'est le président je regarde des
460 milliards de déficit d'envoyer on va
pas je vais pas énumérer mais voilà on a
des indicateurs extrêmement extrêmement
grave donc nous nous pensons que nous
sommes pas dans un nouveau chemin
d'égalité sociale l'égalité territoriale
et l'innovation environnementale et rien
n'a été prouvé du point de vue des
décisions et que nous prenons
aujourd'hui j'aurais dire que
franchement il y avait des choses qu'on
manquait sept milliards cinq qui était
qui sont demandées par les collectivités
territoriales
ces 4 milliards 5 de données dans toutes
les exonérations sociales yapo une seule
condition de contraintes pour les
entreprises qui a été accepté ici
et regardez on a été incapable
d'imaginer des recettes innovantes pour
l'état aucun aucune recette innovantes
dont je dois dire que pour notre groupe
a quand même un élément de satisfaction
c'est qu'on a quand même obtenu quand
même avec votre concours d'avoir taxer
les gaffes
à la mesure de leurs immenses profits on
est content d'avoir arraché 150 millions
pour la recherche scientifique et puis
vais vous dire aussi une satisfaction
qu'on n'obtienne ici et ces autres
résultats communs qu'on arrive à cette
égalité de salaire entre les femmes et
recel on l'a menée par les exonérations
sur merci chers collègues
voilà donc nous ne voterons pas
ce plfr 3 je l'avais dit au début la
confiance pour nous c'est paul une
paresse merci pas une concession à la
paresse merci cher collègue monsieur le
président d'allier simple monsieur le
président monsieur ni simplement pour
vous dire formellement que le groupe
vient républicain votera bien évidemment
ce ce texte tel qu'il a été modifié
parce que beaucoup des mesures que nous
souhaitions voir y figuraient ont été
adoptées par le cnra les mesures
proposées par notre rapporteur général
mais également beaucoup les amendements
du groupe donc nous voterons bien
évidemment ce texte c'est maintenant
notre apathie générale à mission
d'essayer de trouver un accord cmp mais
ça dépendra effectivement des avancées
que l'assemblée nationale acceptera je
pense aux mobilités parce qu'il ya un
vrai sujet une vraie difficulté sur
l'article 18 ce sera probablement plus
facile mais les choses ne sont pas
acquises définitivement on a voté le
plfr 1 et 2 on espère voté le 3 mai
monsieur ni ça dépendra des efforts que
pourra faire le gouvernement et
notamment la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale pour la pour la suite olivier
cadic nous disait que marie ils nous
reprochaient d'avoir trop de voter ce
plfr avec un déficit de 226 milliards
qui nous invitait à faire notre examen
de conscience
mais pour autant il le vote l'examen de
conscience c'est pas ce soir que nous
devrions le faire
on devrait le faire en regardant la
percée la période de dix années passées
parce que c'est là qu'on a raté le coche
ce que les autres ont fait après la
crise de 2008 2010 nous nous ne l'avons
pas fait les voilà pourquoi ça devient
si difficile aujourd'hui alors tirons-en
effectivement des conclusions pour
l'avenir parce qu alors là si jamais les
choses dérapent et notamment en matière
de taux d'intérêt je vous rejoins sur ce
que vous dites sur la dette qui devient
abyssal
là vraiment il faut agir ça ne peut pas
durer
de l'autre côté nos collègues
socialistes nous disent qu'ils ne
voteront pas le texte parce qu'on ne
dépense pas assez écouté le dernier et
je terminerai là dessus l'euro grec nous
avons europe les républicains c'est que
ce texte n'est quand même pas le plan de
relance que nous attendions et là dessus
le gouvernement nous a beaucoup promené
excusez moi le terme sur le ministre
mais on nous l'avait annoncé le plan de
relance dans le plfr 4 on a même entendu
un ministre au banc à l'assemblée nous
dire qu'ils allaient venir
ça devait être en septembre ou ou même
fin août bon il y en a pas on nous dit
maintenant que tout cela peut attendre
la loi de finances pour 2021
voilà nous nous craignons vraiment que
nous perdions six mois et que cela ne
contribuent à aggraver la crise encore
une fois mais ceci étant dit pour ce
soir nous voterons ce plfr 3 et tous nos
remerciements effectivement la
commission des finances aux
administrateurs au personnel du sénat et
avoue également monsieur le président
merci chers collègues le 6ème rang merci
monsieur le président je m'associe
évidemment remerciements qui viennent
d'être faits ce plan de financement
numéro 3 des règles une situation
d'urgence mais combien de le dire
philippe à moyen long terme il n'y a
rien de réglé et nous avons voté hier un
certain nombre de taxes étaient
le jour de la libération fiscale pour
les français c'est pour répondre à nos
collègues de gauche
les français sont les plus imposées
fiscalement et socialement pour des
résultats qui se dégrade
après année après année donc à moyen
long terme on peut qu'être inquiet comme
souligné olivier cadic car on ne
s'adresse vaut rien et depuis 74 nous
votons des budgets en déficit
et ce n'est pas durable à travers
l'histoire il ya trois façons de
résoudre une dette de 126 milliards de
déficit
les trois façons simplement trop façon
c'est la guerre c'est la dévaluation et
c'est la disparition de la monnaie
on n'en connaît pas d'autres alors en
fait on paye le fruit comme le dira
philippe de dix années de cac et deux
quinquennats oms a commencé avant certes
ce cher collègue mais ça coûte rien
c'est l'état qui paye et quoi qu'il en
coûte
réfléchissons à ça et la seule façon de
s'en sortir c'est sûr de la croissance
qui financera des emplois des dividendes
n'ont pas forcément pour les très très
riches parce que si nous étions dans une
économie dans un pays fermé pourra
effectivement mais dans un monde ouvert
dans un monde il ya plus de frontières
on contrôle le moins en moins et les
flux de capitaux et les départs à
l'étranger et bien la solution proposée
par nos camarades de la droite des
musiques c'est tout et c'est tout à fait
faisable donc en tout cas merci et merci
à monsieur le président que nous car est
de vermine et pas trop tard merci chers
collègues
donc je ne vois plus de demandes
d'explications de vote monsieur le
rapporteur simplement j'avais dit en
ouverture que la cape ou de deux
d'humour que le cdh a été beaucoup plus
efficace que l'assemblée nationale parce
qu'il faisait en trois jours ce que
l'assemblée a mis trois semaines à
examiner donc mais ça veut dire qu'ils
aient complètement que nous n'examinons
pas de très bonnes conditions nos textes
nous sommes obligés de travailler des
nuits de week-end et je voulais en
profiter donc pour remercier vous tous
chers collègues est venu et vous êtes
mobilisés ce week-end et compris cette
nuit de dimanche soir c'est un petit peu
inédit remercie monsieur le ministre à
six autres collègues à l'espagnol chez
qui vous êtes succéder au banc pour nous
répondre
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
remercier monsieur le président ainsi
que les autres présidents qui se sont
succédé et remercie tout
particulièrement les collaborateurs
administrateur du sénat qu'albator des
ministres qui sont d'une aide précieuse
et qui aussi ont des vies de famille
qu'il sacrifie en ce moment mais
rassurez vous on va se revoir
l'examen de conscience on la paie tout à
l'heure mais c'est la semaine prochaine
puisqu'on à la loi de règlement en
nouvelle lecture et on a également le
débat d'orientation des finances
publiques donc je vais dire que c'est
parce que demain très bientôt avec tous
mes remerciements à nouveau pour votre
participation
si monsieur le rapporteur général jeu
mais on voit le projet de loi de
finances rectificatif pour 2020 en
application de l'article 59 du règlement
le scrutin public est de droit il va
être procédé dans les conditions fixées
par atik 56 du règlement à ce scrutin
public
le scrutin est ouvert les résultats du
scrutin
numéro 141 sur l'ensemble du texte
compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs ou politique est notifié la
présidence nombre de votants 340 nombre
de suffrages exprimés 334 pour
l'adoption 244 contre 90 le sénat a
adopté
monsieur le ministre un mot monsieur le
président pour m'associer aux
remerciements qui vous ont été adressées
à travers vous à toutes celles et ceux
qui vous ont précédé à la présidence du
sénat est de nos débats ainsi qu'à tous
les collaborateurs qui nous accompagnent
et puis un dernier mot pour remercier
l'ensemble des sénateurs et des
sénatrices pour je crois la qualité et
la sérénité des débats que nous avons
eus pendant plusieurs jours merci à vous
tous les sénateurs ont donc adopté ce
troisième budget d'urgence pour faire
face à la crise du corona virus 45
milliards d'euros débloquée afin de
sauver l'économie et de venir en aide
aux plus démunis et notamment les jeunes
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi vous pouvez
revoir tous nos programmes sur notre
site internet publicsenat.fr je vous
souhaite une très bonne journée sur
public sénat
[Musique]